so let me ask you this so what matters
the most in your world okay so you got
first of all your voice is ridiculous
your voice you know what i'm saying like
you can listen to that voice tell
stories all day long
clearly it'll kick your ass so how much
how much of it is physic like physiology
like what you look like how much of it
is your look your face how much of it is
your voice how much of it is
storytelling how much of it is talking
[ __ ] how much of it is just your
flexibility
what would you rank as the most
important to being a great wrestler
you're really insightful bro because
it's all of that
when you've got the look
and the size
and the rap
and the athleticism
when you put that all together
you've got like stone cold steve austin
you've got the rock you've got uh
goldberg
you know you've got kevin nash like
the guys who
guys who learn to just take themselves
and amp them up
and scott because he was big scott hall
or he was gator scott hall he didn't
really know how to be
like himself and hip himself up until
i'm managing him and we create that look
i told you with the black hair and a
brush cut five o'clock shadow which he
had around two you know
have you seen his beard of course can
you can you pull him up real
quick amazing it's got like a perfect
perfect yeah
and you got
and trying to pull up a picture of him
with a mustache too
like an older picture so you can see it
doesn't look anything like this
type of mustache next to it yeah it's
like a walrus mustache
let's see look at does that look
anything like the other guy
not at all
not at all
that's scott hall right there that's
scott that's big scott hall and when did
he become razor ramon well what happened
was when i come up with this idea for
the diamond stud he's the one who calls
me and says you know we could do that
diamond stud gimmick you know and i said
well you know they didn't want to bring
him in because he'd already been in and
once you've had a chance you're kind of
out you know like sometimes it's too
early and it was too early for him to
get
the big opportunity
but if you change his luck and that's
what i told magdamta the guy who told me
i was too over the top professional
wrestling as a manager
he he said uh
you know
they've already seen him and they don't
want to bring him back in i go banks
what if i can completely change his luck
because what do you mean i go what if
you don't recognize him
so he goes just bring him up bring him
up we'll take a look at him so i call
scott and i say dude
i said you gotta you know they don't
want you and it just crushed him you
know it's like he just got back from
germany wrestling there and he can't get
wwf wwe or wcw to call him back
but he's got me here and i'm going
you got what if we change the color of
your hair
i go he goes what do you mean i go like
go from like the blonde or dirty blonde
hair to the blue black like elvis hair
and hockey talk man had black hair like
that honky tonk man was great yeah and
it's but he was the only one who had
that hair like that it was elvis right
yeah of course and and then
you bring on um
you know the the uh
i saw i saw sean uh i'm not sure michael
i saw uh george michaels on mtv at two
o'clock in the morning cause i'm a club
guy still even though i'm staying with
my buddy in atlanta i can't go to bed
that early so i see george michael on
and he had this five o'clock shadow look
and i go man that looks amazing so i
pick up the phone and i call him
dally what are you doing bro it's two in
the morning my wife's pregnant you know
i go come here i gotta tell you
something you're coming up tomorrow come
on walk out of the room i go you gotta
shave the mustache
shave the mustache
like dude i've had this since i was 15 i
go just another reason shave them
brother
we gotta put the five o'clock shadow
george michael vibes so the bottom line
is he did it
no one recognized them and they kind of
imagine you you know what you look like
yeah and you saw this guy six months ago
and now dude that's the example right
there look at that exactly
no that doesn't even look like the same
guy
crazy
it's like getting out of the 80s into
the 2000s hey yo he would say hey yo
who would say chico who would say him
too right here
cbd you know your stuff right well i
mean listen i mean i'm 43. this is my
era i've watched who was your favorite
wrestler growing up who was your guy
the obvious one is the iron sheik
but you gotta say listen i appreciate
that yeah
do you know what a stud iron cheek used
to be yeah that's what i hear he was an
animal bro he
pound olympic athlete he was no sergeant
slaughter yeah no dude
so who was your guy another great guy i
would say i mean in my era
uh [ __ ] lex luger was always good
who was the other guy the
ultimate warrior was was uh beast you
like the gym guys i like the gym guys
yeah i like the i like to listen
goldberg to me
was that's a little later but goldberg
was insane to watch him nash sting
uh who was the other guy there was one
other guy that was uh
i'll look him up i'll i'll see but
anyways this was an error i was watching
him but you go go back to your story on
what you were talking about with him so
she low so i changed look yeah and now
i've got a 62 pink cadillac convertible
that's what i drive at the time
and aretha franklin box let's see what
it looks like
62 cadillac pink convertible
and we're driving scott didn't even
drink back that he didn't he smoked pot
and he'd be rolling that's it that's a
59. got to get a 62. that's a 59. tyler
it's a 59 [ __ ] you put in if you put
diamond dials paige pink catalyst
he loved the movie scarface
so he would be you know
smoking an herb and just doing wonders
there's a million quotes yeah from scott
my friend mario does that non-stop yeah
and and so what happened was when he
went to the wwf i i'd heard i can't i
don't know if it was true or not but i'm
pretty sure he told me that vince wanted
to make him like gi bro or would not
yeah bro but
an army guy and he said you know vince
what do you think about this and they
went into the character
and then slapped it and then
one of my very good friends gabriel
glacier the comedian
yeah fluffy fluffy said he cried when he
realized he wasn't mexican
he still still loved still is he just a
white guy a young
guy but he played it so well oh he
played
it better than mexicans yeah i i want to
address one thing i mean we're talking
about this guys i gotta just hand it
head on
my favorite wrestler all time grown up
i'm an 80s kid 90s kid
straight up it wasn't anything close to
hulk hogan i am a real american i mean
are you kidding me when you're a kid
growing up you're just like
hell yeah i mean hulk i mean he's got
his 62-inch ply thought whatever look
there was there was the ultimate warrior
there's macho man
i mean jake the snake million dollar man
ted dibiase
super fly jimmy snuck got junk out like
i loved wrestling but nobody was hulk
hogan now he was is he the goat who's
the goat now he said rick flair he's
right here
i gotta say rick when it because you got
you gotta add the work in there too like
rick could do 16-minute broadways
meaning he's gonna wrestle for 60
minutes with no winner at the end you
know i mean like he's that guy and but
if you take the icon who at the time was
the hottest it's hulkster you know but
you look at a guy like shawn michaels
who was
just a younger version who could could
do i mean he did stuff at it's just an
unbelievable different level if stone
cold steve austin has the length of ric
flair when it comes to longevity because
he got dropped on his head and broke his
neck uh you know maybe he's the guy
because he drew money he drew more money
than hulk drew in a shorter period of
time yeah because remember so he's like
conor he would put money
say again because connor you know
countering ufc
right right right right right and that's
austin and austin i mean i know wow
they're both i tell you when you get to
that level the grab how you grab the
crowd like i was so
lucky to live the dream like i did man
1997 was my year 1998 was amazing in 99
and this is all in my 40s
crazy you know all in my 40s and what
ended up happening where don't ddp yoga
thing comes from
i'm working 270 plus days a year hitting
the mat
one match because i'm one main events
through all this so one match could go
15 minutes ago 30.
that's like having five
to eight
car accidents
in one day
and ric flair said something really you
know interesting he said it's amazing
what your body can get used to
so pain tolerance yes
but just your body can you just keep
getting used to it
and then when you stop doing it and you
come back oh my god it's like starting
all over again
so i was working such a feverish pitch
along with doing you know malone carl
malone
and dennis rodman
rodman was with hogan and me and carl
malone came in
while they were on the tonight show and
we shot the angle show malone and ddp
and i have to teach these guys now
how to wrestle
they're not wrestlers so we have to
figure it out
there you go look at that picture beast
like that is the
i i i'll go back and tell you the story
so hulk holds me aside in germany 1994.
i just walked through the curtain
and he pulls me aside he goes how are
you doing it
i go how am i doing what hulk he goes
how are you getting so much better he
goes i don't see you on tv that often
they don't believe in me at the time
they're not using me
so he goes but when i do see you you
come up with some new move i haven't
seen you do and you get the people
involved he goes this is how they're
doing it right he answers his own
question he goes they're putting you on
the road so you can learn your craft
as hell i said hulk the only reason i'm
on this tour
is because my real name is faulkenberg
and the krauts love their germans
and i got a smoking hot wife that walks
me to the ring he goes well how the hell
are you doing it then and i said i went
back down to power plant where i learned
how to wrestle
and i started teaching those guys and
i'm kind of figuring out the more i
teach them the more i learn this is
about everything you know this of course
if you teach someone and keep teaching
them and keep teaching you're learning
as you're teaching the most the most
important thing so
and obviously
great hope i'm thank you i appreciate
the compliment he goes he goes whatever
you're doing
keep doing it because it's not today
it's not next year the year after he
said but i honest to god believe
that you and i could draw huge money
together well
four years later
that is the big second biggest drawing
pay-per-view in the history
of pay-per-views for wcw
and
i'm the one who put that whole thing
together from carl coming in rodman was
already coming in with hulk but i put
the idea together brought at the bishop
bishop saw malone yo
sweep la that year and he said let's do
it and it happened so
it's you know getting you never know
who's watching
you know that's uh that's one of the
little
things i explain to people you know you
what if you're going to clean up your
bathroom or sweep a floor
like do it the right way
because somebody's watching and it might
just change your life that's so powerful
by the way
you never know who's watching no well
listen he's a 270 out of 365. so so
you're working 270 it's like having five
to eight car accidents a day
15 to 30 minutes you're running jumping
back dropping all this stuff that's
insane too too the
credit goes to the body by the way how
capable we are so many times are like
there's no way in the world i can do
this and i've got four kids you watch
the body have a baby you're like how do
you do that the body is so much more
capable than we think we we think it is
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]
you